into this story in his response to his
opponent Bader O'Rourke's Town Hall
earlier we're joined by Texas senator
Ted Cruz senator I went long on that
interview and I'm sorry because I
probably took some of your time but this
is a great family from Texas
their lives have been turned upside down
and hearts broken they don't even get a
call from the former mayor of San
Antonio who's on TV you know talking
about this caravan thing and demonizing
Donald Trump and all Republicans and
didn't even get a call from his brother
who's a congressman from the area where
this kid was burned to death what is
going on in this country senator well
Laura thank you for having MS Vargas on
and for telling her story and telling
Jarrett's story it's heartbreaking it's
tragic and it never should have happened
and you're right that the Democratic
politicians they turn a blind eye to the
suffering to the violent crimes that are
committed committed I was glad to hear
her describe that she's been able to
work with chip Roy a chip as my former
chief of staff and he's the Republican
nominee for Congress out of San Antonio
he's gonna make a terrific congressman
and and miss Vargas should not be
suffering this this this individual this
illegal alien committed multiple crimes
and our revolving door system lets
criminals drug criminals violent
criminals who are illegal aliens stay
here as you noted he got a voluntary
removal order which which he ignored
which is what happens it's the reason we
need to pass Kate's law which I authored
in the Senate that says that aggravated
felon violent criminal illegal aliens
who enter the country illegally
repeatedly should face a mandatory
minimum prison sentence so that violent
criminals are not in our communities
they're not taking lives like that was a
deed but rather protect yeah you're
right but a DWI we we should have
deported him when he committed a DWI
when he was arrested he should have been
put on a plane or put on a bus and sent
back to country he came from we
shouldn't be releasing illegal aliens
who commit DWIs I've met too many Texans
too many people who've lost loved ones
to illegal immigrants who are criminals
who commit DWI is and and it's wrong
and we need to protect our country not
not allow criminals and drug dealers to
come into the country illegally senator
did a fantastic job and the debate the
other night with your opponent mister
o'rourke he's in a town hall earlier
tonight and said this and I'll get your
reaction I decided that I could either
spend the rest of the debate responding
to every single dishonest thing that he
said or I could make sure that everyone
understood exactly what he's doing I
said look he's dishonest it's one of the
reasons that he got tagged with this
nickname and that that nickname
resonates because it's true yeah
obviously the lyin Ted nickname which
was unfortunate from the primary but now
I guess he's quoting the president in
order to make his case I mean it's it
seems like there was no there there I
mean I watched him he's a good-looking
guy there's no there there there's no
like where's the beef well you can see
the disc desperation in that debate
where he was insulting me he was
attacking me he called me a liar what's
striking is what he was responding to
when he screamed liar it is I pointed
out that he voted in favor of a $10 a
barrel tax on every barrel of oil
produced in the state of Texas and his
response is not to engage in substance
but simply scream liar liar liar well
you know facts matter and and and we put
up on our website tedcruz.org the exact
text of the resolution that congressman
O'Rourke voted on President Obama
proposed a $10 a barrel tax on oil
Congress the House of Representatives
brought up a resolution saying we don't
want a ten dollar tax on every barrel of
oil and O'Rourke voted no and and his
receving
is just a scream liar and then that's
that's not on senator senator we're out
of time but we enjoyed that debate I
wouldn't want to debate you and he did
awake no thanks
good luck debate oh it's not going to
happen